on va revenir dans un second temps sur
cette résistance acharnée des civils
avec vous à guillaume de roger bonjour
guillaume êtes consultant france 24 sur
les questions de stratégie je voudrais
d'abord qu'on revienne dans un premier
temps sur ce qui semble s'apparenter une
nouvelle stratégie de l'armée russe on a
dit qu'à un certain moment ses troupes
s'enlise et on avait relevé et constaté
des problèmes elle logistique mais elle
avance c'est trop plus ils avancent ils
gagnent du terrain elles continuent
d'étendre leur offensif est ce qu'ils
sont en train de le faire différemment
est ce que cette stratégie a
effectivement dû être repensée parce
qu'on a vu ces colonnes de blindés se se
disperser s'éclater et puis des soldes a
tenté de de tenir ou de pénétrer kiev
différemment bon avec les les
contraintes évidentes de d'informations
on peut dire qu'un certain nombre de
variables ont permis aux forces russes
d'avancé ces derniers jours de manière
substantielle et d'arriver en réalité
aux portes de deux villes qui vont être
des moments critiques évidemment kiev
qui est le symbole fort le symbole
politique plus forte ouvre le nord et
lens qui seraient encore à l'heure
actuelle où donc le gouvernement
pourrait devenir un gouvernement en exil
si finalement qui a fêté prise et puis
au sud odessa donc pour l'instant bien
sûr le verrou comme le reportage les 10
1/2 de nikolaïev sont de deux verrous
important kiev essentiellement symboles
politiques et plans enjeu fort derrière
avec l'inconnu de toute la stratégie
russe sur le fait de voir la prendre la
contrôle et a conquis real a revendiqué
ou bien finalement d'abord laissé le
pouvoir politique partir faire partir
pouvoir politique pour être renforcés
cette négociation politique et couper
les liens entre le gouvernement et le
peuple ukrainien et puis pour odessa là
c'est potentiellement la confirmation
d'une volonté de
poursuivre un cordon militaire jusqu'à
potentiellement la transnistrie et donc
finalement prendre le contrôle de tout
le sud du mois de la vie votre sentiment
à vous à guillaume c est votre analyse
en tant qu'expert sur ces questions
stratégiques kiev peut tenir encore
quelques heures quelques jours plus
longtemps quelques jours c'est sûr très
fier là dira peut-être peut tenir plus
longtemps ce qui est sûr c'est que ce
qu'on voit depuis deux jours maintenant
7 véritablement à la fois une guerre de
siège une guerre d'attrition avec tout
ce que cela peut comporter d'incertitude
on y reviendra peut-être sur les
tactiques russes est ce qu'ils vont
essayer de téléphoner ville est ce
qu'ils vont rencontrer une résistance
dur sans doute au début il est très très
connu que c'est beaucoup plus difficile
de conquérir une ville que la défendre
et là ça veut dire qu'il faut comprendre
quand on a vu ces colonnes de blindés on
s'en souvient sur 60 km l'a finalement
éclaté se disent pas tout ça veut dire
que les soldats sont au sol et qu'il
tente de danse est au tour de kiev donc
ça veut dire qu'ils attendent quoi
concrètement pour lancer cet assaut
final en réalité c'est tout l'enjeu
d'une allonge
logistique qui évidemment doit alimenter
cette ses actions militaires pour donc
quasiment 200 mille soldats russes sur
le terrain donc on a les avantages de
ces inconvénients c'est que il ya le
nombre il ya l'attrition mais il ya
également il ya évidemment également
l'obligation d'alimenter tout cet effort
et c'est là qu'un point faible peut se
faire jour et qu'une guerre asymétrique
un peu peut se développer de la même
manière qu'on va avoir une guerre c'est
une guerre urbaine qui va qui va sauter
une guérilla guillon on a entendu dans
certains messages à authentifier bien
sûr mais certains soldats russes qui se
disait prêt à renoncer des défections
peut être en cours est ce que ça vous
semble plausible est ce que ça peut
aussi expliquer qu'à un certain moment
c'est armées russes et patiner
je sais pas si des défections
individuelles il y en a il y en a en
fait dès le premier jour en réalité il
ya de la même manière dans l'opinion
publique russe et parmi les citoyens
russes d un des individus qui
manifestent leur opposition à cette
guerre
ne savaient pas qu'ils sont engagés dans
une guerre guillon d'opérations
spéciales mais ont continué leur pas
d'opération jusqu'à un certain point ça
reste pour eux si vous voulez une zone
grise dans laquelle évidemment tout à
toute une partie du pays soutient
vladimir poutine et dans lequel on voit
aussi bien les bénéfices tirés par le
kremlin de dix ans de de recentrage de
l'armée au coeur de la société de
réforme profonde de l'armée une
institution qui est remonté en quelque
sorte à la fois en légitimité en
autorités en particulier auprès des
populations jeunes
donc évidemment on a des phénomènes
individuelle de 20 de remise en cause et
de critiques mais ça n'enlève pas
aujourd'hui l'ampleur l'ampleur de
l'effort